let's see if we can figure out what 30%
of six is so one way of thinking about
30% this literally means 30 per hundred
so you could view this as 30 over 100
times 6 is the same thing as 30 percent
of 6 or you could view this as 30
hundredths times 6 so 0.3 0 times 6 and
we could solve both of these and you'll
see that we'll get the same answer if
you do this multiplication right over
here 30 over 100 and you could view this
times 6 over 1 this is equal to 180 over
100 and let's see we can simplify we can
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 10 and then we can divide the
numerator and the denominator by 2 and
we will get 9 fifths which is the same
thing as 1 and 4/5 and then if we wanted
to write this as a decimal 4/5 is 0.8
and if you want to verify that you could
verify that 5 goes into 4 and there's
going to be a decimal so let's store
some decimals in there it goes into 4
zero times we don't have to worry about
that it goes into 48 times 8 times 5 is
40 subtract you have no remainder and
just have zeros left here so this so 4
fist is 0.8 you got the 1 there this is
the same thing as 1.8 which you would
have gotten if you divided 5 into 9 you
would have gotten 1.8 so 30% of 6 is
equal to 1.8 and we can verify it doing
this way as well so if we were to
multiply 0.30 times 6
let's do that zero point and I could
just write that literally as zero point
3 times 6 times 6 well 3 times 6 is 18
I have only one digit behind the decimal
amongst both of these numbers that I
multiply only have the 3 to the right of
the decimal so I'm only going to have
one number to the right of the decimal
here so I just count one number it's
going to be one point eight so either
way you think about it or calculated 30%
of 6 is one point eight